hey what's going on in spill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday June 5th 2017 what's going on how
are ya how's it going how was your
weekend it's really not Monday morning
at this point I mean it's still my
Monday morning just twenty two [ __ ]
eleven but by the time I finish this
shit's gonna be about noon noon
Saskatoon see the Northern Lights I just
had a [ __ ] amazing weekend I want to
thank everybody who came out to cluster
fest up in San Francisco this new comedy
festival I was up there Sasae and on
Sunday I had like this I had like a
make-a-wish weekend was crazy
I went up there um let's see what did I
do I did the two dope queen podcast then
I did I did the Comedy Jam goddamn
Comedy Jam we playing outside near City
Hall which I called the [ __ ] state
capital anytime I see a dome I'm like
that's got to be the capital of the
state I mean what Wyatt why would they
spend that much [ __ ] money making
something look that impressive and all
it is is just city whole you tell me the
[ __ ] mayor lives there Jesus Christ
I'd love to see the governor governor's
above the mayor right is that how it
works
it's like metermaid then it goes mayor
then governor and state representative
congressman right and then a senator and
then the MotoGP level is you're the
[ __ ] you're the president all right
tweets and gets up and storms out of
interviews when he doesn't like the
questions the [ __ ] is going on with it
you know I watched this thing on now
what's his face of lottie dottie their
Vladimir Putin saying like how like
anybody who's like an opponent of his
they stay [ __ ] kill him as they've
had all these weird suicides this one
guy tied himself to a chair and somehow
threw himself into a pool
that one right there is not only getting
rid of your enemy but it's also
displaying your level of power because
when you're not even trying to hide it
like that oh yeah that was a suicide
anyways and then he's like poison and
[ __ ] people in all this [ __ ] whenever
I watch those should never watch up um
stories about people like that there was
this guy he's gotten poisoned twice
first time he went into a coma for a
week and he was in the hospital for like
a [ __ ] month now he walks with like a
limp and he went right back to
protesting you know the current regime
in Russia and then he [ __ ] they
poisoned him again he goes to the same
hospital this time they realized you
know with his symptoms gone alright this
guy's probably been poison against they
knew something a little better so they
got him out like a week to ten days I
don't know about you guys the first time
I get poisoned and I and I live I'm
gonna say to the cause listen guys I'm
passing the torch okay I did my part I'm
going to uh I'm going to start making
those furry Russian hats I'm going to
open a little [ __ ] kiosk down at the
local people's mall whatever the [ __ ] it
is it you know it's funny as everybody
thinks Russia's communist right somebody
told me that the old day going like that
do they have been communists for like
[ __ ] 25 years they're like over here
it's like a small group of people
running [ __ ] except they you know rather
than tweeting and walking out on [ __ ]
they just kind of poison people they're
taking it to the next level I believe
the kids say it's turnt up um but
anyways cluster fest I just survived I
went to bed watching that dies I started
talking about a Comedy Festival and then
I go over talking about a guy getting
poisoned and continuing to do with the
[ __ ] I've ever got poison doing
stand-up that said I'm done I'm done I
would just I would send out a tweet to
whom whoever poisoned me what would you
like me to be doing with my life so I
can get on with that
stockroom at Best Buy you got it I'll
[ __ ] load and unload flat-screen TVs
for the rest of my [ __ ] life do not
go into another week-long coma and stay
in the hospital for a goddamn month
knowing that there's people out there
that not only can poison me I don't know
who the [ __ ] they are and when they did
it dude was just sitting there talking
to his wife everything's fine
and out of [ __ ] nowhere he went from
feeling obscene yeah you know I feel a
little why is it hot in here boom right
into a coma two [ __ ] 20 minutes later
continues to fight the good fight that's
amazing that's amazing you know if there
is an afterlife or whatever I feel like
that guy's in the pre checked TSA line
you know just goes right through I saw
this little view Tube video on this guy
who allegedly had a 200 IQ and I guess
the average person has a hundred you get
up to about 130 140 you're a [ __ ]
genius
you know [ __ ] Tesla had a 150 [ __ ]
Galileo at a 160 somebody had a 190 and
this guy's got a 200 so he's allegedly
the smartest person on the [ __ ]
planet and he lives in the [ __ ]
middle of nowhere on a goddamn farm with
like a couple of yaks and some chickens
he met some other super genius woman out
of Brooklyn I don't know if you heard
him both talk I didn't buy it
I didn't buy first I don't know what's
his wife started talking and it's just
they never really made him demonstrate
how [ __ ] smart he was he just was
talking about what he was doing he was
trying to prove that heaven exists so
right there that was suspect to me I was
just kind of like going like all right
this guy's like the smartest person ever
he's like a [ __ ] religious freak you
know I don't know that's always a I
haven't found too many smart people that
are like that level into religion I have
found smart people into religion but
they're kind of like and it's what I
believe you don't believe it I get it
but you know it works for me so well I
have a nice day
it's supposed to telling you you're
gonna [ __ ] burn forever or some [ __ ]
I don't know
like I was trying to prove the existence
I have and what about Hell
does that exist I don't [ __ ] know
I'll send a I'll post it is I wasn't
supposed to say I'll post the [ __ ]
clip anyways make it back to cluster
fest I'm [ __ ] talking in circles here
so yeah so I landed I did a private gig
and then I did two Broke Girls then I
played drums at the goddamn Comedy Jam
outside the [ __ ] mayor's house in
this giant square there was a couple
thousand people there and I forgot to
adjust this one symbol so I bring my
stick up this my he had like the [ __ ]
crash symbol the other drum we had the
crash symbol Nick right above and I kept
hitting it and I was missions [ __ ] I was
[ __ ] up but I just kept going it's
kind of a learning experience like I
[ __ ] up a lot I thought and I just
kept going and somehow it landed on its
feet and then later on that night I did
a show there I don't know how many
[ __ ] people were there it was frees
it was a coldest I've ever been doing
stand-up it's just like outside you know
save for those people who don't live in
San Francisco and I've made this mistake
because I took a vacation there a long
time ago in July and I dressed like it
was July San Francisco summer I believe
is like end of September to like middle
of October it's really quick and the
rest of the time it is [ __ ] freezing
so I was in this little [ __ ] trailer
in the back which always cracks me up
about this business know you like I'm
gonna make it someday I'm gonna be a
star and you end up in a [ __ ] trailer
park for most of your career so I'm in
this trailer right not even a
double-wide I'm [ __ ] sitting there
and I'll by the way Les Claypool band
played across the way before I went up
so I got to hear them play I couldn't
see him play but I got to meet him
briefly this is my make-a-wish weekend I
just [ __ ] broke out the double pedal
and I've been trying to play
Tommy the cat and that type of [ __ ]
which I'm failing miserably at and Here
I am meeting the [ __ ] guy that wrote
the goddamn song he was cool as hell
his band sounded amazing and uh yes I
was standing there and I did a show was
me Joe DeRosa and Pete Davidson and I
was sitting in the trailer trying to get
warm you know learning from the East
Coast going all right if I'm already
cold with my hoodie and my jacket on I
need to take this [ __ ] off and let my
body adjust so when I go out there when
I put the hoodie and jacket on up I'll
be all right that's something you learn
as a kid if you already put all your
snow [ __ ] on inside the house and your
body adjusts your temperature in the
house with that [ __ ] on you can then go
outside and you can be freezing cold I
don't know why how it works
that's how it works you got to take your
[ __ ] jacket off so I was doing that
and as I'm doing it
I'm listening to DeRosa and he's
murdering in like the laughs he's
getting is not opening a show laughs and
he went out there like no pun intended
cold there was no nothing no music I
don't know what the [ __ ] was just
ladies and gentlement Joe DeRosa and he
walked out to the parking lot where the
hell we were performing and he was
getting laughs that were not open or
laughs and then he brought up Pete
Davidson and he's [ __ ] killing just
as hard both of them absolutely murdered
whoever was at the show I know can back
me up on that and then I went out there
and it was uh who's one of the more
memorable shows I've had with like the
the mayor's house there they had the
dome it was all lit up and like this
Celtics green which was pretty cool and
where they'd sat everybody they would
like these traffic lights that were
telling you to walk or not walk and I
kept you know was seeing the sign when
they were counting down whether it was
safe to walk across the alleged traffic
that was no longer there I kept thinking
that was like the end of my set it was
like [ __ ] me up and whenever the red
light came on I'm like is that mean to
wrap it up I kept it on it's a [ __ ]
traffic light
I don't know anyway so I did that and
then on Sunday though then I went to a
big after-party you got to hang out with
DeRosa big J Nate bargatze all these
[ __ ] guys man just having a great
time and then the next day I got
to interview Jerry Seinfeld promoting
his comedians in cars getting coffee
that's going to be out on Netflix and I
can't even tell you how [ __ ] nervous
I was to do that
cuz I was just like all right I was
joking in the interview only I always
feel like I'm one dumb comment away from
you just standing up and just walking
out of the room and I never see again
like that's the vibe he has and as I
said that he stood up and just walked
out of the starts to walk off the stage
I was like really nervous because I
thought that uh yeah I don't know I just
thought he was going to give really
quick short answers and I was just gonna
be sitting there like Chris Farley when
he did that sketch what he and I
interviewed Paul McCartney like remember
we did Seinfeld that was awesome like I
thought I was really gonna be that guy
but um within two seconds I realized oh
wait this guy did The Tonight Show with
Johnny Carson you know why wouldn't he
come out here and absolutely [ __ ]
kill it if he just sat here giving me
quick answers the thing would go nowhere
and then he would look bad with me
it was amazing was all the most fun
things I've gotten to do in my career
and you know before I interviewed him
for whatever I Paul the I had all these
[ __ ] questions like I was gonna look
at Mike I never interviewed somebody
like that so I had all these questions I
was going to ask him you know his
favorite car of all time his favorite
met of all-time
you know what level dictator would you
still be willing to do a private show
for you know what I mean
and I never even had to look at him nice
a few of those I think I asked him who
his favorite Met was I forget who he
said it was someone from like the 69
series but it's probably that guy that
douve caught the ball but before I went
on and interviewed him I was looking up
you know some information about just so
I would have something I was trying to
think what the [ __ ] and I asked this guy
that he's not been asked a million times
before and I just happened to see it
says Jerry Seinfeld comments on Kathy
Griffin controversy and they cut tone
they're just like Jerry why do you think
about Kathy Griffin bla bla bla bla bla
bla
and he just goes it's stupid who cares
that was it and I was like oh my god
is he going to do that when I interview
him is it going to be that quick and
thank God thank God he didn't thank God
he didn't so it went great
thank Christ and then I the interview
ended I don't know we were just saying
man that was a lot of fun that went
great it was awesome and then he left
and then me and Josh Adam Maya's jumped
in a car didn't really jump in a car
Jerry jumped in his car because he does
life right you know he gave me some
great advice about being on the road he
said when the show's over he just goes
go back to the room he goes go back to
the room and I go you ever just want to
go out and have a couple he goes go back
to the room it helps there's nothing
nothing good is out there just go back
to the room and you know I already knew
that do you how many times I've learned
that [ __ ] lesson and he said to me he
goes if you want to look this good in
your 60s go back to the room and he
looks [ __ ] great so I'm going to try
to do that how do you go back to the
room you don't go back to the room you
have no stories I'm gonna be in Montreal
this weekend how do I go back to the
room one of my favorite cigar bars in
the [ __ ] world is there how do I go
back to the room but I have to tell you
every time I go back to the room I'm
come hating it right till I get to the
elevator and then I go up in the
elevator and I go into the room and I
put the TV on in the second I get into
the bed I'm like oh my god this is
awesome this is [ __ ] great I don't
know why I just you know I think I
finished the show I'm wired I'm excited
it went well and then I you know I go on
the road with friends and they're always
what do you think maybe go have a couple
two or tree and I always say yes I
always say yes so anyway so the show
ends I've learned to go back
the room I've also learned to have the
car serviced right [ __ ] there
like Jerry it was just just just like
his act there was no fat on him [ __ ]
leaving the stage going to the dressing
room getting his [ __ ] and he just walked
right out and I said I go yeah of course
I go look at the guy this is how you do
your life the [ __ ] cars ready my guys
like I don't know where the [ __ ] he is
and he just laughed and he just got in
his card it was over so I usually don't
have any sort of a car service I usually
just walk out ok so the reason why I
have a car service was because I had
tickets to go to the game to the NBA
Finals
my make-a-wish weekend continues so my
car guy goes yeah I'm [ __ ] dude I'm
[ __ ] deaf the street in the car
garage and I go I saw her right here I
told him where we're at come to the
stage door the dude comes to the stage
door on foot and walked us back to the
[ __ ] car the show ended at 3:45 the
finals started at 5 o'clock so I'm like
what the [ __ ] man so we walked all the
way over to this parking garage got in
the elevator went downstairs I'm way I'm
in the parking garage with the crowd
it's the most anti show business thing
ever it's the most anti Elvis left the
[ __ ] building was [ __ ] pedestrian
it was shameful I should have had my
urine show business card revoked so we
get in the car we're sitting in the
traffic with the [ __ ] crowd to get
out of the parking garage
nothing VIP about a complete [ __ ]
[ __ ] I am so we ended up me and Josh
we're riding in the car over and we're
just laughing oh dude we're going to the
[ __ ] NBA Finals finals why would ever
the [ __ ] you say and and we had a couple
of cigars and we said to the guy who
turned out to be the greatest driver
ever we were like dude is that okay if I
don't get the guy in trouble he may or
may not allegedly have let us smoke
cigar in the back of the car and we
ended up getting to the finals and we
missed about half of the first quarter
and it's just one of those things like I
can't believe I'm here and I love that
[ __ ] or
rina it's going to be a shame when they
leave it I'm going to tell warrior fans
right now enjoy that arena because your
next arena is not going to be that loud
the new ones are never that loud because
they build in all of those luxury boxes
and everything is just so [ __ ] big
and far away from the court but anyway
so we go to the game and we're watching
the game and it's [ __ ] you know it's
great through about the first two and a
half quarters and then the Warriors just
start pulling away and I got to tell you
as a fan of sport and competition that
Kevin Durant the lowington Durant to go
to the Warriors was that's out of all
those things LeBron going to Miami
[ __ ] Kevin Garnett and Ray Allen
going to the Celtics Shaq and Phil
Jackson going to the Lakers this one
might be the worst one because at least
like like Shaq and Phil Jackson that was
a bad time but still you still had like
the Spurs they attempt unka need a
Vetrov Anson you know he still had
something to compete with and you know
the Celtics when we won we stole the
beat the [ __ ] Lakers and God knows
they always had nine million [ __ ]
free agents and even the [ __ ] Heat
that first year they lost to the
Mavericks but this one it was just like
I'm trying to think of an analogy to
compare be like if Matt Magic Johnson
joined the Celtics Oh Larry Bird joined
the Lakers after the 1985 championship
when we lost him in the finals he just
joined the [ __ ] Lakers um I got oh
yeah it just felt it felt [ __ ] dirty
when I was watching it going like this
just doesn't feel good it just I don't
know I wasn't an NBA final game and I
was actually bored which is funny
because I I thought when I was at home I
didn't know what the warrior fans were
chanting when they were saying warrior
Wario's I thought they were chanting
boring boring I literally thought that
that's what they were saying because
there was so much look at last year's
Western Conference Finals that was
[ __ ] unbelievable that seven-game
series with the Thunder and the Warriors
and then you look at last year's NBA
final was [ __ ] amazing went 7 games
and was won in the last second by the
Cavaliers it was incredible basketball
incredible level of competition it was
amazing and then I don't know I don't
understand how the Chris Paul trade was
bad for basketball but Kevin Durant
going to the Warriors and then just
watching puffing their chests out and
punching it [ __ ] chess and in the
crowd going crazy as if they don't
realize what they're watching like
acting is so like yeah man this year's
our year last year you beat us but you
know what we dug down deep and now you
did you did you picked up the best guy
that almost [ __ ] beat you last year
and added it to your team it was like I
don't know every time they get to within
three to five points what I have to tell
you it's pretty [ __ ] amazing when
you're playing a team they haven't even
lost a game yet they've lost one game
since February and they were already
playing like that before they had Kevin
Durant so I'm not trying to rain on
people's parade here or anything but uh
I really don't have anything to say
about the game other than I will for me
i watch sports to watch competition I
don't watch it to watch a layup I mean
the fact that they have all of those
guys and then then they can rotate them
out and when they LeBron is sitting down
they got another to LeBron still out
there it's just [ __ ] I don't know
there was a lot I don't know there was a
lot of like I just couldn't believe I
didn't hear one warrior fan address it
you know at some point just kind of be
like yeah
is kind of a I mean at any Celtic fans
out there you didn't feel like dude what
the [ __ ] that year in 2000 we were like
in last place and then kevin mchale's in
the front office of the Timberwolves and
trades away Kevin Garnett for nothing a
former Celtic does that to the
Timberwolves like that should have been
investigated the same way the Pau Gasol
trade when what's-his-face Jerry West
was in the front office
of the Grizzlies yeah we'll give you Pau
Gasol for his [ __ ] brother who's now
good but he wasn't back then
it's a horrible [ __ ] trade those were
bad enough but I think this is the worst
one ever like this is um I'm still
holding out I have to root for the
Cavaliers I'm still rooting for the fact
that they can somehow you know obviously
they got to win the next one most
obvious [ __ ] statement ever but yeah
I got to tell you from about halfway
through the third quarter I started
pulling away and then the Cavaliers kept
fighting back and they just had it was
it was ridiculous it was like I don't
know I just walked out of there going
like that felt like a [ __ ]
regular-season game I didn't feel like I
don't know I don't know I don't know I
will have a [ __ ] somebody explain to
me what that that's competition like
it's a warrior fan you're gonna look at
that and just be like yeah man that
feels good and you have to be honest
with yourself warrior fans weren't you
guys bitching at LeBron when he went to
Miami and he won two down there right
weren't you saying that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] to pile on team now if you were
you got to say that about your own
[ __ ] team and I didn't hear that once
I just saw everybody [ __ ] walking
around thumping their chest like this
was the greatest [ __ ]
thing ever you know else is funny too I
really think it's hilarious is when the
little kids come out and they do their
dance routines that aggressive hip-hop
dancing it's the funniest [ __ ] ever to
me like what dancing has become it's
like you're literally sitting there like
one little kid dance when I was a kid it
was cute it was
adorable now you just sitting there like
this does this kid want to fight me I
think a six-year-old is squaring off
with me this whole [ __ ] new
generation where everybody's just
walking around like they're these gods I
don't know what the [ __ ] that is about
these [ __ ] Instagram douchebags who
are trying to be inspirational people as
they're showing off their [ __ ] ABS
like like they're trying to help you by
showing off their beauty and their own
success and standing in front of private
jets holding up a wad of cash
I just I kept for the [ __ ] life of me
I can't understand why that behavior
isn't ridiculed and why it's actually
like aspired to go out and get yours so
[ __ ] get what a bunch of [ __ ]
shoes I don't know Wow God I'm just a
crappy old man I have to tell you if the
Cleveland Cavaliers and somehow signed a
giant free agent at the level of Kevin
Durant then I think this would be
probably the greatest NBA Finals ever
because it would be like two Hall of
Fame [ __ ] teams going at it with each
other and then even if I you know I
always hated that [ __ ] you know I
hate the super tapes as you can
obviously tell but at least if you have
two of them going at it then it becomes
interesting like back in the day when
the roided-up free agent Red Sox went up
against the roided-up free agent Yankees
I know it was bad for baseball but at
least it was I don't know there was
another roided-up free agency [ __ ]
team out there this is just like um I
don't know I just don't understand how
you play a team that has the talent that
LeBron has and it's like [ __ ] child's
play because you got this other this
[ __ ] juggernaut you just signed in
that I don't know it was weird it was a
weird feeling leaving there
so I think I [ __ ] I don't know I think
that was a little too long I probably
talked about it too long but like I was
so excited to go to the [ __ ] game and
then you just it would have a nice of
one warrior fan with like yeah you know
it's kind of [ __ ] but you know you
know bran did in Miami so does that kind
of make it okay
I mean hey you know that guy touched a
kid so why can't we touch a kid right
doesn't isn't that how it MIT it's not
how it works
yeah I was joking with Josh I go to that
felt dirty and then I also have to tell
you I absolutely [ __ ] cannot stand
the West Coast the West Coast [ __ ]
sports fan I just cannot stand them I
did not hear one intelligent thing
yelled during the game I mean their
their their commentary is different
reads of oh [ __ ] now that's it nobody
[ __ ] seems to know what's going on
there was one guy behind me going on I
never seen the Cavs come out with this
lineup oh they're going big there was a
couple of people but everybody else was
just [ __ ] mouth breathers just
waiting for the ball to go through the
net to be like oh they don't want none
it is I'm sorry
give me the [ __ ] blow out your ears
there all right um all right I'm done
[ __ ] whining about that [ __ ] but it
is [ __ ] it is I actually heard this
one this is a [ __ ] West Coast sports
fan I went into the bathroom and
somebody yelled out two championships
going on three and somebody goes two and
a half we got two and a half I don't
know if he was saying like they should
have got it called a championship last
year or they're already racking this one
up because they already [ __ ] we're
gonna win game two I don't know I don't
[ __ ] him I have no I have no idea I hope
that that's what that guy was saying do
you think I [ __ ] on the whole [ __ ]
thing long enough I really didn't think
it was going to go that long I'm already
[ __ ] 28 minutes in alright let's do a
little bit of advertising here oh by the
way rest in peace blue apron blue apron
decided not to go
you advertising with me because I said
you know when they were reading the copy
it says you know when you have fresh
ingredients food tastes better I was
like really fresh and green face better
that's the reason they're claiming that
they stopped wanting to advertise in the
podcast not because six weeks ago I read
that story where they were you know
going to farmers markets trying to box
out the little man
you know I know that's what it was I
know that they just were like well we
can't do it now or he's going to bring
that [ __ ] up that filthy [ __ ] that we
allegedly did up again so we're just
going to wait and we're going to wait
for him to do one [ __ ] read that we
don't like and then we're going to be
out come on blue apron how dumb do you
think I am huh stop going down to farm
farmers markets allegedly you know what
do you want junk cougar mellencamp you
have to write another [ __ ] song is
that what the hell you going after all
right here's our here's our old friends
they don't give a [ __ ] how I read these
theses I like these guys this is all zip
code are you hiring do you know where to
post you Joe well are you do you know
where to post your job to find you know
what I got to start the street over
again you know what I was just thinking
I bet if I turned on ESPN you turn on
ESPN you know if and when the Warriors
win the championship it I bet those
[ __ ] guys they're not going to
address it on any level they're gonna be
like where do you mean they went 62 no
where do you put there to the pantheon
of various teams of all time
I mean even the 96 Bulls lost two games
it's a great game ever they're gonna do
that and they will never address a
[ __ ] ridiculous citizen how bad for
basketball it was that Durant left the
Thunder just a [ __ ] go pile on
[ __ ] pile on anyway sorry Oh zip but
Colonel are you hiring
boy are you is that what you're doing do
you know where to post your job to find
the best candidates talk about the
challenge of finding great talent and
/or the importance of finding great
talent is accept to it with successful
business oh I got to tell you
when I walked down the street with my
sandwich boy going who's talented you
know it's really hard and I always think
you know I wish there was a better way
you know because you know in order to
win you got to [ __ ] have all the best
guys on one team
so they win by 30 every night dude you
realize the [ __ ] Cavaliers scored 63
or 64 points in the first half and they
was still down by five I mean what do
you got to do
you scored 64 65 points usually up by 10
or 15 how zip recruiter is different
with zip recruiter you can post you know
and this is what the West Coast sports
fans just going to say hater that's all
they got
I don't know if it's because they get up
three hours later than people on the
East Coast but they I know they just
baked their brains in the Sun but I
don't know if funny I'll tell you the
rough out here you know how zip
recruiter is different with zip
recruiter you can post your job to
100-plus job sites with just one click
then they're powerful technology
efficiently matches the right people to
do your job better than anyone else
that's why zip recruiter is different
unlike other job sites
doesn't depend on candidates finding you
it finds them in fact over 80% of jobs
posted on zip recruiter get get a
qualified candidate in just 24 hours no
juggling emails or calls to your office
simply screen rate and manage candidates
all in one place with zip recruiters
easy-to-use dashboard find out today why
zip has been used by businesses of all
sizes to find the most qualified job
candidates and a medium with immediate
results and right now my listeners can
post jobs on zip recruiter for free
ebike that's right free by just going to
zip recruit comm / birth at zip recruit
accom / / one more time for free go to
zip dot-com / / um all right how many
more of these FARC and things you know I
should piss off more people I could fly
through this part of the podcast all
right who do we got here Oh dollar shave
club Dollar Shave Club is the smarter
choice you get a great shave at a great
price conveniently delivered right to
your door
do you want to stop nicking your balls
when you shave them you no longer have
to schlep to a store to do it by a
cheaper a disposable razor that gave you
a cheap shave or spend a fortune on
razors with gimmicky shaving you didn't
need you don't need to do that [ __ ] and
when you use Dollar Shave club's
executive Raiders a razor with their
doctor cavies easy the blade gently
glides across giving you the smooth
shave gently glides over your ball bag
and down to your taint how do you guys
shave your balls do you go from [ __ ]
up to the ball bag do you come up and
over the horizon is the Sun rising or
setting over your ball bag dr. cow dr.
Carver's shea butter is transparent for
a more precise shave helps prevent
ingrown hairs and fights razor bumps
make the smarter choice by joining
dollar shave club for a limited time new
members can get their first month of the
executive razor with their tube of dr.
cabbies easy but only for five dollars
with free shipping after that the razors
are just a few bucks a month that's a 15
dollar value for only 5 bucks there's no
hidden fees no commitments cancel
anytime you like you can only get this
offer exclusively at dollarshaveclub.com
/ / that's dollarshaveclub.com / burr
oh [ __ ] ProFlowers this is the last one
I'm going to read then I'm gonna go back
to the podcast and I'll read these other
three later ProFlowers have you ever
forgotten your anniversary if you're
nodding yup huh um you're lying what
have you ever forgotten your anniversary
if you're not if you're not nodding yes
you're lying
the [ __ ] are you talking about well I
guess I forgotten mining that I booked
shows not realizing was my anniversary I
don't think about my anniversary till
it's coming up anyways you know that
those people that are just hard to shop
for like your wife for your your
anniversary or your sister for her
birthday it's the worst thing trying to
get that perfect gift a you know they'll
try to get that gift a you know they
like and be won't cost an arm and a leg
well I'm gonna make it easy for you just
get them a bunch of [ __ ] flowers here
you go sweetheart
thanks for being you Pro flowers
evidently is my go-to for
flowers they're fresh priced right and
our perfect gift for literally anyone
ProFlowers you got to stop acting like
this is the only thing you got to do
ProFlowers is the perfect accoutrement
to something else that you get a woman
wants something thoughtful and flowers
they definitely want flowers you have to
[ __ ] get them flowers but she also
got to get him something else I don't
give a [ __ ] if you go down and get him a
zagnut bar the fact that you got in the
car or you were in a grocery store and
you thought about them and you get them
flowers BAM that's it all right that's
it and guess what about these flowers
they're fresh they're priced right and
are a perfect gift for literally anyone
they're fresh yeah they rob them off
somebody's freshly dug grave and they
delete it get delivered straight to your
recipients door how easy is that
and right now ProFlowers has a special
offer for our listeners get $10 off your
purchase for up twenty nine dollars or
more this deal works on best selling
gifts like 100 blooms bouquet a dozen
red roses or even there at total quality
unique plant gifts to snag this great
deal just go to proflowers.com and enter
the code bar at checkout so right now
get $10 off your first purchase of
twenty nine dollars or more at
ProFlowers but this deal definitely
won't last long just go to
proflowers.com and enter promo code bar
at checkout to get this special deal
this is great too if you have someone in
your life that's on the other side of
the [ __ ] country you don't I mean
bing-bang-boom it's right there it's
like you thought about me smile
alright anyways here we go alright let's
read some questions here for this week
see if I can stop talking about that
[ __ ] Golden State thing hey Bill
would love if you would find it I would
love I would love it if you would find
it to come back to Sweden Malmo gets
boring there's too few redheads to spend
my money on here thank you all right I
feel like he was vaguely trashing me yet
he likes my comedy I'm definitely going
to be coming back to Sweden last time I
went through Europe I didn't do the
Scandinavian countries what are the
Scandinavian countries people come on
Norway Sweden
ah Denmark I know there's one other one
in there it's not Finland that's part of
the Nordic countries that also includes
Scandinavia I can't even remember it's
been so long since I was there I learned
that Scandinavia was like three
countries and then those three countries
are part of the Nordic countries which
included Finland and this little island
just north of Great Britain right isn't
something like that I will definitely be
back and I'll have a brand new hour if
you [ __ ] blue-eyed blonde-haired
[ __ ] and we'll have a great time from a
lovely French lady hey Bill hello
Bonjour I just wanted to say I just want
to send a little message and hopefully
have it heard that being a video vide
videographer myself i immensely
appreciate the graphic work in details
and f is for family oh thank you such a
great show on so many levels that's it
all the best to everyone involved with
Bill in general and of course Bill
himself a French fan fan from Patty hey
guess what French lady femme de la
France a lady of the France of um the
show is actually that the animators is
Goemon which is in France all right and
then of course you know then they farm
it out to these people big jump in
Ottawa that's how it works but you guys
are part of the mix and what's great
about France is if you use French
animators an animation company is you
get the government gives a little bit of
money it makes it cheaper you know it's
a smart thing it's like a Trump thing
they're trying to bring [ __ ] business
you know into their country like Trump
says he wants to do as he walks away
from the Paris agreement it's just a
hoax climate change not global warming
anymore its climate change sheds still
changing the climate I saw some lady on
TV going like you know I
it's good for this country that we do it
and because we've always been a leader
in environmental issues yes we have been
a leader [ __ ] [ __ ] it up the most
as far as I can tell if I'm to believe
what the scientists are saying Oh
scientists their information anyways by
the way thank you to everybody that's
been watching season two the people have
been loving it and you know it's a ton
of goddamn work so thank God you guys
enjoyed it or have been enjoying it
please tell more people to watch it the
more people you tell to watch it
hopefully the more fans we get and then
they'll let us do it season three um you
know and if not I'll just have all kinds
of free time in my life it's kind of a
win-win for me either way people either
I get to continue working with these
great people doing this great show or
I'm gonna become a hell of a drummer
alright well thank you so much and I
can't wait to get back to France at some
point just get away to the little one
gets a little bit bigger
we're actually I want to do I was
talking estudia I want to get like some
sort of [ __ ] you know French person
over here right that can you know help
make my daughter smart cuz she's got to
learn from somebody I know ain't gonna
be me and she also teaches her French
and teaches us all French how great
would that be my little cutiepie be over
in France speak being fluent huh how
cute would that be you know she's
sitting up by herself now it's [ __ ]
amazing she has this look on her face
she's like proud of herself it's the
cutest thing I've ever seen in my life
it's just the best I'm telling you it's
the best there's no material and having
a kid there really isn't other than your
fear that something bad is going to
happen to him but I feel like that's
been [ __ ] done to death you know what
I mean other than that it's just it's
been [ __ ] phenomenal ok f is for
family hey Bill I'm a big fan of your
work in from Puerto Rico hope you hope
to see you perform someday here I
watched the second season of efforts for
family and is great even better than the
FIR
one completely hilarious well take care
and keep the good work keep up the good
work
how how would that work you know Puerto
Rico is like not a state but it's one of
those yet another place that we kind of
just decided was ours if I go on stage
there - I got unliked I went on stage
and Singapore it and get caned I'm sure
I'll be alright in Porto Rico
I'd love to [ __ ] go there bring my
wife she can go to the [ __ ] beach you
know I'll be there with all the lovely
ladies all those [ __ ] JLo's walking
around I think that would be that I
could I could definitely be talked into
that I go over there and tell my [ __ ]
[ __ ] jokes all right can't stop smoking
cigarettes alright get job on new season
get job on the new season of f is for
family I'm halfway through and it's
hilarious I've been smoking for seven
years now I'm 22 and I can't stop
smoking it's really starting to affect
my health and I'm sick of it
I quit boozing and smoking weed but I've
never been able to quit smoking
cigarettes alright and what the [ __ ] how
do I help you do this I tried to replace
it with Wii but it just makes me want to
smoke a cigarette after alcohol gives me
cravings - you used to smoke cigars so
maybe you've got some good tips I still
smoke cigars to help me quit by the way
you should come to Minneapolis soon and
play a show check out the new Vikings
stadium it's amazing
let's see you guys yeah the twin stadium
is amazing you guys are doing all right
up there as it's the wilds the last time
I went to uh I went - what are you out
of that the Timberwolves game Kevin
Garnett was still there and you played
in the Target Center and that was a [ __ ]
hole
alright well they say quitting
cigarettes is as hard as quitting heroin
so I don't know I I would try to get
professional help I'm so happy I never
started doing that and
you know I don't like I used to smoke
cigars like you know once every like
four days or something like that now I
smoke them like once every two weeks
sometimes three weeks and I really don't
have the craving to do it I kind of wait
for like the right time to do it like
riding in a car to go over to the NBA
Finals that felt like yeah this is a
cigar [ __ ] moment but the way I was
doing it before was just like [ __ ]
you know every goddamn a couple of days
like you know having a humidor and all
that type of stuff you can really just I
don't know I I still think I smoked too
many of them and I don't eat right when
I'm on the road and I drink too much
when I'm on the road and it's something
I have personally I have to stop doing
that I and you know what it is it's
really I find it's just developing I
know people say this but it's just
developing new habits like you know if
you're eating [ __ ] food you crave [ __ ]
food if you're eating salads and good
stuff you crave that and I don't know
I'm a creature habit if it's just like
every night you know we're going out
we're having drinks after the show it
just because it's just your body's like
oh now we do this it's in like this
routine so you kind of have to force
yourself to break up your routine and I
think you just have to make a decision
that you're going to be stronger than it
you know unless you have like some sort
of you know super addictive like
personality like those people and you
got to go into the dr. Drew house or
some [ __ ] like that I mean I don't know
what your deal is but I would definitely
I would seek professional help
all right VIP airline hey Bill that
airline with the hot air hostesses exist
it only flies between Paris and New York
oh I was talking about a VIP airline we
don't have to go on with people that I'm
going to take their shoes off and put
their feet up over the goddamn you know
sticking between your [ __ ]
what are they doing sticking between the
[ __ ] armrest in that type of thing
just those goddamn animals they should
just have a first class one they should
have animal Airlines and then [ __ ]
raised right Airlines so he's saying
there is a VIP airline but it only flies
between Paris and New York it's only
business class they give you iPads feed
you chef made food and plenty of good
French wine the tickets aren't even that
expensive treat Nia to a holiday best
from France well what's the name of the
[ __ ] airline you got to give me the
name of the airline dude now I got to
look it up no way I got to tell you I
look at you know I got time to [ __ ]
do this will my internet even work
[ __ ] scam that that is all right VIP
airline New York to Paris come on what
do you say this American Airlines New
York to Paris flights
Air France the Campania discover Paris
with the unique from all ball business
class airline I found it it's LA CEO
mpag and ie calm 18 hundred bucks dude
you said it was a thousand I want to see
some pictures here plane your trip to
Paris oh wow okay I'm impressed with
their little terminal there Mike upon
you know dude I live in LA I live in LA
so I'm not going to [ __ ] connect
through New York I'm just gonna say [ __ ]
it use all my miles and jump on a plane
I got forever in New York that be nice
thing to do maybe I'm doing a gig in New
York then afterwards we can just go fly
overhead it's a good idea goddamn it
that's a good [ __ ] idea who knows
melts all that's the wife about that one
you know what I mean you know that works
well that was a question I wanted to ask
Jerry I forgot to do I want to ask him
do can you just come home with a new
Porsche or do you have to clear it with
your wife you know can you get to a
[ __ ] like can you just look here and
be like dude I'm Jerry Seinfeld
you know look around your house do you
like this this echo echo
all right heart surgeon busted for
filming me taking a piss what beer dear
Billy double-take tits I got the [ __ ]
that me that's hilarious
I heard the story on your podcast last
week [ __ ] phone keeps vibrating this
whole podcast the phone fart rang right
what the [ __ ] is all of this stuff oh
Jesus Christ all right here we go I
heard the story on your podcast last
week about the Oxford students stabbing
her boyfriend in the leg with a butter
knife and how she was let off easy
despite her psychotic actions I have a
similar story that involved myself a
little while ago
I'm a musician and was playing a solo
gig near some markets in the popular
popular part of Brisbane where the [ __ ]
is that I've been there oh that's
Australia Australia huh that was the
next thing let me said calm I went to
the next page [ __ ] hilarious not
during one of my breaks I went to take a
leak in the public amenities I was doing
my business in one of the stalls when
suddenly I noticed an iPhone slowly
coming over the top of my stall to my
left i can only see half of the foam but
could tell the camera was going
obviously it took me by surprise and for
about two seconds my head went through
does not compute mode I was only halfway
through taking a piss I said what the
[ __ ] out loud when I heard the stall
next to mine opened very quickly I look
behind me and saw a short possibly asian
guy running I tried to stop mid pissed
very difficult adjusted myself quickly
ran and ran out after him only to find
hundreds of people walking through the
markets I couldn't see him anywhere I
was infuriated it was infuriating my
first thought was oh great now I'm going
to be uploaded to some quote I love
public pissing contouring site I was
really [ __ ] pissed off nope
tended from this guy evidently but kind
of glad I didn't catch him because I
probably would have dragged him by the
balls to the police and then they would
charge me for his soul I don't think you
would because it's a guy to guy physical
confrontation and on his phone that
would be your dick anyways a few days
later I was telling my friend what had
happened and he said that he heard about
an Asian German national being caught
filming seven men in the public toilets
in the same area and he found the
article online so it turns out this 26
year old guy is a trainee heart surgeon
on holiday in Australia celebrating his
graduation from medical school here's
the article what the [ __ ]
wait a minute wait a minute well Lisi
doesn't work on somebody's [ __ ]
urinary tract him he's he's uh he at
least had enough discipline to be like
listen I can't be near the dick area I
don't trust myself to he's up by the
[ __ ] hot um okay this this article is
slowly but surely opening what what is
the what is going on in the world the
judge went easy on him and didn't record
a conviction because of his promising
career what the [ __ ] I guess if you're a
doctor you can get away with anything
what the [ __ ] so just because you're an
elite student in this world you get let
off easy for doing really fucked-up
things apparently none of the other men
filmed were aware of what he was doing
so I called the police in the area he
was caught they asked me to describe
what I was wearing at the time bla bla
bla and said the phone was confiscating
that footage was deleted I [ __ ] hope
so they also act I was him saying then I
just gave it a great read so it sounded
like me if I could pat myself on the
back they also asked if I wanted to
press charges I said [ __ ] yes the cop I
spoke to said he would pay the pervert a
visit very soon to lay the charges as
the guy was due to leave the country in
two days I called back on the day he was
supposed to leave the country but the
cops said they wouldn't won't be
pressing charges because they had
already been laid by the arresting
officer and that the student had
received a conviction even though the
article said he had
weird but apparently he will never be
able to enter Australia again for the
rest of his life I just think it's so
[ __ ] up that these people can get away
with such disgraceful actions especially
someone like this heart surgeon who
could potentially be playing with some
poor guys balls as he lays under the
anesthetic I'd love to hear your
thoughts well they kind of have the guy
in check because heart surgery you need
other people oh here's a guy German
tourists with died Tran was fined 800
bucks
sounds like about a hundred dollars a
dick after pleading guilty to several
seven counts oh seven counts seven and
eight hundred so he's been about 159
yeah but on a 15 bucks a thwack or
something like that under 12 bucks I
don't know counts of recording in breach
of privacy a training heart surgery okay
this guy 26 a German national Jesus
Christ even [ __ ] Asians if they go to
Germany that becomes sex perverts I
thought it was just the Germans what is
it with that country they just ended the
peon in the shittin what the [ __ ] is
going on over there so he's fine
800 bucks after pleading guilty to the
Brisbin magistrate and Saturday on seven
counts of recording in breach of privacy
the court heard Lee had been in
Australia for a month to celebrate his
recent graduation for medical school
when he was when he filmed the naked men
on Friday Lee films seven men in the
space of three hours by holding his
iPhone over the wall of the neighboring
cubicle
none of the men realized they were being
filmed but his behavior drew the
attention of south bank security who
contacted police Lee was arrested police
found the video of the men on his phone
acting Magistrate Bob blood described
his ass actions it's disgusting the
offenses of disgusting the offences are
disgusting offenses involving a serious
breach of the privacy of other adult
males that can only assume the offending
was for sexual gratification purposes
Lee's lawyer Kate Makar
to set her client had been accepted into
cardiology unit in Germany and would fly
home on January 12th he is a very
promising career ahead of him she said
she said her client was ashamed of his
actions but asking that a conviction not
be recorded against him because it could
jeopardize his career and ability to
travel mr. Schubert finally $800 and did
not record a conviction wow man
you know that's [ __ ] up that's really
[ __ ] up that's really [ __ ] up and am
I crazy to think that because these
these actions are against men you know
some happens to a guy it's just not as
serious I don't think you know I just
think that's I don't know either people
like yeah you know they think it's funny
like if this is saying if a woman told
another woman that's some woman I guess
was filming and they'd be like what the
[ __ ] no wait maybe because it was a
woman though but last week was a woman
she had she stabbed the guy with the
knife maybe it isn't any of these issues
maybe this is just if you listen if you
want to get away with [ __ ] and you don't
want to be a banker or being the in an
insurance company then I would say get
into have a promising medical career in
front of you evidently that just
absolves you of everything that's really
upsetting all right let's let's see what
he and the only way to follow up that
upsetting story is the only thing I know
that's more upsetting than somebody
filming another man peeing without him
knowing was me reading out loud he likes
everybody Alex you're unique oh you're a
special [ __ ] snowflake you don't walk
like everybody else talk like everybody
else sure Jay or sleep like anyone else
so why is your mattress one size fits
all what army movie is that from your
mothers are not here anymore
I'm gonna teach you how to walk talk gym
share lock it out thanks Michael because
a truly customized mattress will cost
you five to ten thousand bucks until now
go to helix helix sleep calm answer
few simple questions and they'll run a
3d biomechanical model of your body
through the proprietary algorithms they
developed with the help of the world's
leading arigon omics and biomechanic
experts whatever the [ __ ] that means I
think you just got cloned the result the
most comfortable mattress you've ever
slept on just ask your replacement I
love sleeping on this mattress helix
customers report a 30% improvement over
all sleep quality and for couples they
customize each side of the mattress the
beginning of the end of your
relationship your mattress arrives at
your door in about a week and shipping
is 100% free that's why everyone from GQ
magazine to Forbes are all talking about
helix sleep you have 100 nights to try
it out and if you don't like it they'll
pick it up for free and give you a 100%
refund no questions asked
go to HELOCs Leap calm slash bar and get
$50 off your order
that's helix sleep calm slash bar hey
he'll like sleep calm slash bar
upside man you know something there's a
better way for you to buy business
travel man it's called upside calm and
if you want to get rid of the middleman
man every time you buy a trip at upside
you'll save your company a ton of money
and they'll give you an amazon gift card
worth hundreds of dollars
upsides able to do this because they
bundle your flights and hotel together
for one low price bundled pricing saves
money if you're a frequent business
traveler your company saves a ton of
money and you get thousands a year in
gift cards just for buying your air and
hotel together at upside plus you still
get all your miles I mean they got
everything in here about a [ __ ] if
you're shopping for business you'd be
crazy not to check out upside comm it
takes three minutes to see how much you
can save by buying your flights and
hotel together for one low price and
right now when you use when you use my
name bar you're guaranteed to get at
least a $100 Amazon gift card for your
first trip you can buy a little $80
camera and go into a men's restroom as
long as you're in the medical field and
film other guys peeing and evidently
you'll be fine that's my name burr to
get at least a one
Amazon giftcard say big on travel and
get a big gift card every trip I love
upside comm evidently upside calm
minimum purchase required see site for
complete details ah there it is men a
minimum purchase required I was going to
say you can't just get get a [ __ ]
$150 flight and give a guy a hundred L
gift card of me you're going to go under
alright stamps.com everybody's stamps
saves you time and money which you can
use to grow your business you know or
stab your boyfriend with a butter knife
I mean you got all y'all this time now I
can mail any letter any package just
using my computer and printer and the
mailman just comes and picks it up avoid
the hassle man I go into the post office
and mail everything from postcards to
envelopes to packages domestic or
international create your stamps account
in minutes online with no equipment to
lease and no long term commitments I use
stamps com anytime I'm selling my
[ __ ] bat I'm whoring myself out
selling posters or whatever if I can
figure out how to use it so can you and
right now you too can enjoy the
stamps.com service with a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale without long
term commitments so go to stamps com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in bar that stamps
calm and tuber stamps.com never go to
the post office again that's it it's a
[ __ ] wrap alright alright so what do
we got here what do I got left to talk
about oh how about the [ __ ] Nashville
Predators making it a series winning
Game three what I hope the Cavaliers do
what I still believe the Cavaliers can
do despite the fact I'm not gonna get
back into that again um
the Predators win Game three I saw a
little bit of it I was working that
night and I actually saw when they went
ahead to one and then three one was that
the game I can't remember so here we go
I mean from what I've heard they've been
out playing the Penguins at at least two
out of the three games so maybe they'll
tie it up
and maybe someone like myself will get
what I want which is a nice seven-game
series a nice classic so that games
tonight I will definitely be watching
and this week this week Oh Billy red
face I want to be on Howard Stern on
Wednesday Wednesday with my triumphant
return I have not been on that show
since I believe 2003 I did it twice in
one month I thought I was an in guy in
and I never got another invite so I'm
finally coming back you know I'm psyched
psyched to finally come back onto the
show so please listen on Wednesday and
that's it that's the podcast thank you
for listening and then really man no
joke thank you to everybody who's been
watching efforts for family telling
people about it and then also taking the
time to let me know how much you're
enjoying it uh it's just it's it's
really been one of the great weeks of my
life I have to be honest with you so no
jokes or anything thank you guys for
watching it please continue to tell
people about it and because we already
have seats we know we want to do in
season three we just have to wait for
Netflix to give us the green light and
they give us the green light by you guys
watching it and talking about it online
which you guys are doing so I can't
thank you enough and and that's it thank
you to everybody at cluster fest I had a
great time thinking to the city of San
Francisco uh thank you to the Warriors
for still playing in the Oracle you know
great [ __ ] old oh you know it's funny
when I did that Seinfeld interview
jokingly said that this this venue feels
like an old ABA arena and evidently the
old San Francisco warriors used to play
there so it felt pretty good about
calling that one all right bill your
overstaying your welcome
okay go [ __ ] yourselves I'll check in on
you on Thursday and that's it let's go
Cavs come on man if you beat the [ __ ]
Warriors with all their accoutrements
that they added all of that [ __ ]
juggernaut of a goddamn team walking
around thumping themselves in the chest
as if what they're doing
I've said this for [ __ ] ever and I'll
say the last time when you were a little
kid on the playground and you were
choosing up teams even little kids knew
when it was getting to when I was not
allowed this this is not going to
there's no competition here even as kids
you knew this the Warriors are doing
right now they're doing something that
even children know are wrong even
children would break that up you know I
really think it is I think Stern left
the NBA maybe that's what it is maybe he
would have stepped in who knows I always
thought that that guy was Shady
I do know this without a doubt
Cleveland's going to win a [ __ ] game
because the NBA does not make money as
nearly as much money on a four-game
series versus five six seven so at some
point I'm looking for them to [ __ ]
just start calling everything on the
Warriors but then again I am a [ __ ]
conspiracy theory [ __ ] freak I don't
know I still feel like the Cavs have not
played the best game yet all right I'm
gonna say they're gonna win Game three
[ __ ] putting it out there all right
go [ __ ] yourselves I'll see you on
Thursday
you